today the issue is the highest political
priority was of course to reach the
general approach on a traffic regulation
on the European solidarity core this
initiative aims to strengthen cohesion
solidarity and democracy in Europe by
offering young people possibilities for
volunteering
trainer ship all working on solidarity
related projects across Europe young
people will also be able to propose
their own project which they think will
be helpful for their own communities I
am proud that the Commission contributed
to their debate with a new policy
communication setting out our vision on
how to build a European education area
by 2025 and the minister's adopted
council conclusions on promoting access
to concern where digital means with a
focus on audience development
conclusions also recommend the use of
the European yeah of culture heritage
2018 as a platform to promote public
access to digital heritage and increase
cultural participation
secondly the council and council held
the policy debate on the role of culture
in building a cohesive society the first
item at the sport Council is adoption of
the council conclusions on the role of
coaches in society the third item will
be the policy debate on the main
challenges facing sport in the 21st
century and cooperation between the EU
governments and sports movement I have
launched an initiative asking sport
organizations to commit to implement
good governance principles our erasmus+
programme can and does provide financial
support for this we can make progress
only with regard to these social values
of sport as it is the IOC mission
according to our Olympic Charter to put
sport at the service of a society